this massive bookstore
sells hundreds of rare and expensive
[Music]
books
welcome to the last bookstore a
sprawling shop in los angeles where the
written word is still alive
at 22 000 square feet it's the largest
bookstore in the entire state of
california
you can get almost anything here but
they're most famous for their collection
of rare and expensive books
and we're here today to find out how
much one of those pricey page toners
would cost you
there are a lot of factors that go into
a book's rarity
and there are a few different ways that
it happens obviously titles that
become significant so you've got things
like
the sound and the theory or the grapes
of wrath titles that are older but
people
value highly still talk about still read
if you can find an
intact first edition first printing with
a jacket
that's worth a lot of money because that
book is significant to
someone if a title itself or an author
themselves becomes precious to a reader
that can increase
the value of a book because that reader
is willing to spend a lot
to have an important artifact they carry
anything
from contemporary titles to rare out of
print copies
this first edition of ernest hemingway's
the sun also rises cost 1200
the cost is partially due to an errata
on page 181
where the word stopped is spelled with
three p's
this is all so cool i'm like oh my god
is that like a first edition of jack
carrack is that a first date yeah
yes oh my god yes to both the most
expensive book sold at the last
bookstore was a signed
limited edition copy of jack kerouac's
visions of cody
it cost 300
we've been here a few times before but
it seemed really cool it's a really good
atmosphere especially for sitting down
reading and finding thousands of new
books
here's a book about me this is great and
all the people here are just so
appreciative of having the opportunity
to really kind of look through all of
these books i mean
even if you go into a standard bookstore
now they don't have a selection like
this
so the question is are rare books a good
investment
[Music]
i think in the same way that an
investment in art is
a little bit risky you don't know what
artists are going to become
major artists later on and whose work
will increase in value and whose work
will just sort of stay at the same level
of value
i think books are similar there are some
books that
are always going to have a lot of value
associated with them
you know if we're talking like first
folio shakespeare
first edition charles dickens first
edition jane austen
those i think are going to have a stable
if not
increasing value collecting rare and
expensive books definitely isn't for
everyone
but that's not all they're known for
here at the last bookstore they have an
entire section of one dollar books
so you can really get anything you're
looking for and discover something new
the staff is extremely helpful
and everyone here seems really eager to
share the love of reading with anyone
who walks in the door